Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux!
Alors si pour nous,
l'immortalité est encore un rêve lointain,
certains animaux s'en rapprochent vraiment
et ont développé
des capacités extraordinaires
pour survivre dans des conditions
totalement improbables.
C'est parti pour mon Top 5 des animaux qui résistent à tout.
On commence par un animal
qui pourrait sortir
tout droit de Stranger
Things : le tardigrade.
Regardez le, avec sa drôle de tête.
On le surnomme aussi l'ourson d'eau.
Ce petit animal de moins d'un millimètre
et doté de huit pattes
est un champion des conditions
extrêmes.
Il résiste à des températures allant
de -273 degrés à +150 degrés.
Il est capable de vivre au plus profond
des océans,
au beau milieu des déserts ou encore aux sommets des plus hautes montagnes.
Il peut se priver d'eau et de nourriture
pendant des décennies.
Les rayons X ne lui font presque
aucun effet.
Il survit même dans l'espace.
Alors, comment fait-il ?
Son secret porte le nom de cryptobiose.
C'est une sorte de mini mort.
Quand il entre en cryptobiose,
il se recroqueville, se déshydrate,
perd 99% de toute son eau,
et la remplace par un sucre :
le tréhalose, qui lui sert d'antigel
et protège sa structure cellulaire.
Cet état de quasi mort
peut durer des années, sans soucis.
Il lui suffit juste de se réhydrater
pour se réveiller.
Je parlais d'espace, il y a une minute.
C'est vraisemblablement le seul animal
qui soit présent sur la Lune.
Il ne s'y est pas rendu tout seul.
En 2019, une sonde y a été envoyée avec à son bord 1 000 tardigrades.
Alors, même si nous n'avons
pas de nouvelles d'eux depuis,
il est fort probable qu'avec de telles capacités, certains aient survécu.
Le ratel, c'est un cousin du blaireau.
Il vit en Afrique et en Inde.
S'il semble à première vue
sympathique, c'est l'un des animaux
les plus agressifs au monde.
Et on peut dire que rien,
ou presque, ne lui fait peur.
Il est capable de s'attaquer
à des serpents ou des proies
beaucoup plus grosses que lui,
des antilopes ou des gnous.
Le ratel est du genre blindé.
Sa peau, très épaisse, résiste
à la plupart des morsures et des piqûres.
Il n'a pas peur de s'attaquer
aux nids d'abeilles
pour se gaver de larves et de miel. Un mets dont il raffole.
Un régime qui lui vaut d'ailleurs son nom anglais Honey Badger, le blaireau à miel.
Non seulement il a la peau dure,
mais cette peau est aussi très lâche.
Si un lion l'attrape par le cou,
par exemple, il peut se contorsionner
et lui décocher un coup de patte
libérateur.
Enfin, il est quasiment immunisé
contre le venin de certains serpents.
S'il est mordu par une vipère heurtante,
il tombe dans le coma
quelques heures,
puis se réveille et finit son repas.
Et comme si cela ne suffisait
pas, le ratel peut aussi,
comme le putois, lâcher
une odeur redoutable.
Un dur à cuire, je vous dis !
On continue avec un animal
que vous connaissez tous.
Il vit dans la mer et en général,
on n'aime pas trop le croiser : la méduse.
Et pourtant, la plupart d'entre
elles sont parfaitement inoffensives.
L'une d'entre elles est très particulière.
Elle a un nom un peu compliqué : Turritopsis Nutricula.
Elle est presque immortelle.
Elle est minuscule,
mesure 4 à 5 millimètres
de diamètre
et est originaire des Caraïbes.
Elle est dotée d'un super-pouvoir
qui méduse les scientifiques.
Elle est capable de rajeunir. J'explique.
Comme toutes les méduses, elle commence sa vie sous forme de polype.
A ce stade, elle a l'allure d'un petit
cylindre mou accroché au fond marin.
Puis le polype se multiplie, grandit,
se détache et devient une méduse libre dans l'océan.
Et c'est là que l'incroyable se produit.
Elle arrive à alterner des cycles
de vieillissement et de rajeunissement.
En clair, elle redevient polype,
puis repasse à l'état de méduse,
et ainsi de suite.
Un peu comme si vous et moi
redevenions enfant,
puis adulte, puis enfant, etc.
En théorie, elle est donc immortelle.
Et comme vous pouvez l'imaginer,
de nombreux chercheurs se sont penchés
sur son cas pour percer son secret.
Mais ce n'est pas encore fait.
Si ce format vous plaît,
n'hésitez pas à liker la vidéo, à vous abonner et à activer la petite cloche.
Je ferai d'autres vidéos de ce type.
On reste dans l'eau pour s'intéresser
à un très vieil animal
que beaucoup d'entre nous aiment bien,
surtout dans l'assiette :
la praire. Celle dont je vais vous parler
vient d'Islande.
C'est un coquillage bivalve
qui vit dans les profondeurs sous-marines
de l'Atlantique Nord.
Et si elle se trouve dans ce Top 5,
c'est pour une raison bien simple.
C'est l'un des plus vieux animaux
jamais identifiés sur la planète.
Un spécimen découvert en 2006
était âgé de 507 ans.
Ce qui veut dire que cette praire a vu
le jour en 1499.
Quelques années
seulement après que Christophe Colomb
ait posé le pied en Amérique.
À l'époque,
c'est Louis XII qui règne sur la France.
En Chine,
c'est la dynastie Ming qui est au pouvoir.
Je vous donne cette info,
car c'est le nom que les scientifiques
ont donné à cette praire :
la praire Ming. La pauvre n'est
malheureusement plus de ce monde.
Elle n'a pas fini dans une assiette.
Elle est morte
suite à une erreur de manipulation
lors de son examen après sa découverte.
Alors, comment a-t-on déterminé son âge ?
Eh bien, en comptant les anneaux de croissance sur sa coquille.
Un peu comme on le fait avec les cernes
d'un arbre.
Les chercheurs ont aussi découvert
que pour atteindre cet âge canonique,
la praire d'Islande est capable de ralentir
le vieillissement de ses cellules.
Un mécanisme qui intéresse
beaucoup les scientifiques, et qui pourrait,
une fois maîtrisé,
être utile pour la santé humaine.
Vraiment !
Ce coquillage a tout pour praire.
Allez, on reste encore un peu dans l'eau
avec un autre animal aquatique
qui a la capacité de se régénérer.
Une légende prétend
qu'un ver de terre coupé en deux
peut repousser
et donner deux vers de terre.
C'est faux.
Et dans la grande majorité des cas,
le ver de terre meurt.
Mais ce que le ver de terre
ne peut pas accomplir,
la planaire, elle, peut le faire.
Concrètement,
si une planaire est coupée en deux,
chacune des parties reconstitue
le morceau qui lui manque.
Elle se régénère.
Et tout ça en quelques jours seulement.
En 1898, le scientifique américain
Thomas Morgan, considéré
comme le père de la génétique, a même coupé une planaire en 276 morceaux
et a obtenu 276 planaires .
Je ne sais pas vous,
mais moi, je suis vert.
Si cette vidéo vous a plu, n'hésitez
pas à liker. Allez, à dans deux semaines.
Salut les Epicurieuses et les Epicurieux !